[Music]
for the last show of 2016 let's unpack
the two words that everything circled
back to for me this past year classical
liberalism we've had many conversations
on the Rubin report focusing on
classical liberalism and how this
political philosophy is different than
both progressivism and libertarianism
for subtle but important reasons for
those of you who are a little late to
the party classical liberalism can be
defined as a political ideology that
values the freedom of individuals
including the freedom of religion speech
press assembly and markets as well as
limited government it developed in 18th
century Europe and drew on the economic
writings of Adam Smith and the growing
notion of social progress so as you can
see freedom is right at the top of the
pyramid of importance to a classical
liberal you have freedom to practice any
religion you want or none at all
freedom of the press to hold the
government accountable freedom of
assembly to protest those in power and
freedom for the markets to move the
economy all of these are vital in the
eyes of a classical liberal these ideas
are rooted in the liberty of the
individual and a limited government of
course when you say things like liberty
and individual and limited government
these words are usually thought of as
libertarian or conservative ideas this
is why some of my critics say I'm
actually a right winger I'm not bothered
by this charge because it doesn't even
make sense if you understand the
original meaning of liberalism as I just
laid out when people say to me you're
not a liberal what they're really trying
to say is you're not a progressive I'll
get to more on that just a second a true
liberal is for gay marriage because they
believe a gay person should have the
same rights as a straight person a true
liberal is pro-choice because they
believe it is the right of the woman to
do with her body as she sees fit a true
liberal is for a legalization of
marijuana because you should be allowed
to smoke whatever you want in your own
home a lot of this sounds like
libertarianism which I know is scary for
a lot of card-carrying liberals to hear
but this is exactly where we can start
building bridges to a new political
center
so what then is the difference between a
classical liberal and a libertarian and
how is a classical liberal not on the
right there's a couple things at play
here first off there's the dirty little
truth that classical liberalism is
technically more a part of the American
right because of the importance it puts
on individual freedom I know a lot of
liberals don't want to hear that or
believe that they could be part of the
right and I also know that the
left-right paradigm is rapidly crumbling
as the two-party system is becoming more
archaic the reason liberalism became so
identified with the left is because of
social liberalism which took over in the
mid nineteenth century for a while this
brand of liberalism worked and helped
tremendously causing huge social change
like equality for black people and for
women at some point though social
liberalism change from judging people on
the content of their character as Martin
Luther King jr. professed to instead
judging people on immutable
characteristics like skin color or
sexuality this was the shift that
liberalism made to progressivism which
places the group over the individual and
ultimately in my opinion isn't very
progressive or liberal at all by judging
people as groups instead of as
individuals the minorities within a
minority will always be thrown under the
bus this is where the social justice
ideology came from a liberalism which
was rooted in the amorphous term social
instead of the clearly defined word
Liberty that's why being liberal these
days in the classical sense has very
little to do with being on the left
anymore silencing dissent the
platforming speakers hurling unfair
charges of racism and bigotry aren't
liberal ideas at all although sadly
they've become part and parcel of
today's left as I often say the road to
hell is paved with good intentions and I
have no doubt that most progressives
believe they are correct in their
thinking so it's our job as liberals to
show them where they've gone awry then
and only then can true liberalism be
part of the left again as I've mentioned
before
I love the convergence of classical
liberal and libertarian ideas because it
shows that two different ideologies can
come to the same conclusions if they're
based in individualism and liberty so if
you're a liberal who's for gay marriage
because you want gay people to be
treated under the law that's just as
good as a libertarian who wants the
government out of your personal life
altogether there's many other places
where you can apply this line of
thinking which begs the question what's
the difference actually between a
classical liberal and a libertarian I've
discussed this with a few guests in my
partnership with learn Liberty and would
recommend that you check out my
interviews with Steve Davies of the
London School of Economics and Randy
Barnett from Georgetown University for
more on that
long story short classical liberals do
see some valid role for government to
the ends that it enhances human freedom
libertarians for as much as you can
define them are a bit harder to pin down
on this notion
speaking of learn liberty we're
continuing our partnership with them
this week and joining me is author of 17
books yeah 17 books economist and former
professor of English history economics
and communications at the University of
Illinois at Chicago Deirdre McCloskey
Deirdre also happens to be transgender
transitioning to female over 20 years
ago we'll talk about her journey both
personally and professionally and how
individualism liberty and freedom are
the keys to a prosperous economy and a
rewarding life as we look towards 2017
let's refocus on freedom liberty and the
rights of the individual the voice is
trying to tear us apart have made it
very clear that they're only going to
get louder and angrier Russia and fake
news are not the problem we are only
when we look in the mirror and are
willing to challenge ourselves to be
more tolerant of other opinions can we
find real answers the only way that we
can drown out the extremists on both
sides of the political spectrum is by
finding allies where we used to find
enemies I've said it before and I'll say
it again if you're an old-school liberal
your enemy is no longer the old-school
conservative defending liberal
principles has become a conservative
position as we enter
new year let's all take the liberal
position of extending the olive branch
instead of extending the middle finger
[Music]